juliette binoche apparemment ce serait
vous qui aurait soufflé l'idée à
olivier comme non mais comment ça s'est
passé réellement
mais avec le bicross il vous fait
c'est mieux ou tant mieux le vent le
vent des montagnes suisses j'ai appelé
olivier parce qu'on avait tourné l'heure
d'été et j'avais été un peu frustré
parce que je trouvais qu'il avait peur
des femmes ils avaient peur de moi il
avait caché derrière ses techniciens et
ça va vraiment je me dis non mais moi je
veux le connaître ce type là est donc je
les ai appelé et m'a dit bah écoute
laisse moi réfléchir deux semaines et
puis si l'idée me fleurimont à ce moment
là je te rappelle et puis pourquoi pas
et deux semaines après olivier m'a
appelé et il m'a dit écoute l'idée
m'intéresse donc je crois je vais
développer le scénario
mr tarantino jean luc godard asine
surtout des oiseaux pour man alphacan
date mins man without any value
à
exagérer on n'a pas du tout exagéré
antoine et on s'étonnera pas du tout
tant qu'on a la preuve c'était sur
france inter avant-hier regarder il vous
intéresse tarantino nous en plus morts
chacun d'un pauvre garçon mais tant
mieux s'il est heureux
ah bah voilà règlement de comptes à ok
cana
il y a
vous aviez déclaré xavier que rien ne
pourrait égaler votre première
standing-ovation à cannes c'était pour
j'ai tué ma mère il ya cinq ans quand on
voit celle qui vous a été réservé hier
c'était énorme c'était plus de 12
minutes cela plus long gain de cette
quinzaine je vous repose la question
quand même c'était plus fort ou pas la
dernière fois
oui quand est ce que j'ai dit ça à la
fois précédente je pense que c'était
c'était avant-hier
non oui
non le lien qui unit égale ça c'était
mais s'était senti on sentait qu'il y
avait un il y ait une électricité le
générique de le générique de fin a
commencé puis le noir ces faits puis les
il ya eu un crime
quelque chose comme une charge
électrique qui montent les gens se sont
levés nous aussi
et l'homicide longoria
a tous nos casseroles
mon chirurgien esthétique m'a
complètement ratée je suis
meg ryan oui nicole kidman oui mickey
rourke hui les frères bogdanoff oui
sophia loren oui c'est duster stallone
est oui
isabelle adjani
albert
oui oui
c'est du jamais vu en cinéma à l'étoile
a
vraiment on apprend à l'instant que line
renaud vient de finir la montée des
marches 2013
voudrais aussi remercier
et sans la moindre des démagogies tout
public de la croisette
d'avoir été là tous les soirs malgré la
chaleur malgré les intempéries
et la pluie pour
la plaisanterie facile
écoutez nos interviews approximative
merci à vous merci
et
mais
le nord
tu sais